allez on ouvre la page sanitaires à
présent avec la situation en russie face
à la hausse des cas de contamination
le parlement examine un projet de loi
pour mettre en place un pass sanitaire
voyez les détails de notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman
avant même l'introduction du pass
sanitaire en russie le projet de loi
doit être examiné par le parlement russe
dans les meilleurs délais les autorités
s'explique déjà quant à sa conformité
vis-à-vis de la constitution russe pour
la directrice de l' agence fédérale
rospotrebnadzor anneaux popova il ne
s'agit pas de violations des droits de
l'homme parce qu'il n'est pas question
d'exiger le pass sanitaires pour les
magasins vendant des produits de
première nécessité ou les pharmacies
union australienne
il y à 77 d'entités territoriales dans
le pays est aujourd'hui peut être même
plus qui ont introduit des codes qr pour
fréquenter certains lieux mais je tiens
à attirer votre attention sur le fait
que les codes qr se sont introduits que
pour se rendre dans les endroits dont la
visite ne représente pas une nécessité
vitale personnes introduit ou ne propose
d'introduire des codes qr pour se rendre
aux gens les pharmacies les magasins
d'alimentation et les magasins de
produits de première nécessité les codes
qr sont introduits là où cela ne viole
pas les droits de l'homme afin que les
contacts entre les personnes ne mène pas
à de nouveaux cas d'infection des cas
graves et des décès
sinon pour ce qui est de la situation
épidémique les contaminations continue à
baisser plus de trente six mille
nouveaux cas de couronnes à virus ont
été recensés 1 aussi dont près de 2900 à
moscou après les pics de plus de 40000
est dans le pays et plus de 8000 dans la
capitale la mortalité à son tour elle
reste à un niveau très élevé 1211 décès
ont été enregistrés ces dernières 24
heures le chiffre dépasse 1000 décès par
jour depuis presque un mois